um you know at the core of it what I  keep wondering is what does any human  really really want yes they want you  know lack of suffering and the whole  Maslow's hierarchy of needs but the root  root thing people want is to be seen and  witnessed and acknowledged in that sense  of connection and community right I  think what it is is going against that  sense of separation right it's it's like  returning to that communal feeling these  are things search used to provide and  now you know the modern church doesn't  have that same context but we are trying  to synthesize alternatives whether it's  Burning Man or raves or cuddle puddles  or whatever it is things that bring us  back to that sense of connection you  know those fleeting moments where it's  like wow I am you you are me we are all  we're all sort of connected we're  different reflections of each other you  know  [Applause]